i'm a big fan of chelsea's uh
and she is great uh and uh we have fun
yeah you heard that right new york
governor andrew cuomo
isn't ruling out a romance with chelsea
handler
but only if they follow pandemic
guidelines
obvi on my dating life uh you know i am
only
dating at this point in state residence
right
i vote i'm dating new york residents and
so
if chelsea changes her residence then
maybe we can work it out i'll say that
the 62 year old politician appeared on
the view thursday
and was shown a clip of the 45 year old
comedian
joking about her crush on him i did have
a conversation with cuomo
a few months ago and i did ask him out
on a date
and he did say yes and then i never
heard from him yep
the eligible bachelor totally ghosted
her
he's like wear a mask i'm like i'll wear
a mask i'll put a mask on every part of
my body
i want to flatten your curve and you can
flatten my curve i've had a lot of
conversations about flattening the curve
but never quite that way and andrew
joked about following new york's travel
restrictions and only dating women who
live in state
but the dad of three didn't rule out the
possibility of dating chelsea
if she moved to new york i'm saying that
i'm telling you
don't say that but she
earlier this month e.t caught up with
chelsea and she
didn't shy away from talking about her
crush
why is he so appealing to you and
is he aware that you have a thing for
him
i think he's aware i think he's yeah he
is aware but
yeah i was really listen we were all
feeling it you know
a lot of women and a lot of gay guys
were also and probably a lot of straight
guys to be quite honest
we needed a man on the scene we haven't
had leadership in so long we had this
man this big italian meatball
coming to the fore and was who looked
like the incredible hulk and he's like
yeah i'm gonna flatten your curve i'm
like i'm gonna flatten your curve
and then we're gonna apex together so i
had a very deep
deep crush on him and yes i was very
public about it so i i he does know
you